it's the first of five straight weekends
with no buys that means plenty of games
let's get right to them stats take me
through the slate to come on sunday no
ravens go to atlanta to take on the
falcons lamar jackson mike over under on
rush yards for him for this game i put
it at 50.
i'll take the over that doesn't mean i
think the ravens are gonna win you know
initially i thought baltimore can go
down to atlanta it's the city where mike
vick became mike vick and mike vick's
been in lamar jackson's corner saying
jackson can be better than i was but
look the falcons are desperate and
they're up against it people are going
to get fired if they don't turn this
thing around at four and seven after
they went from one and four to four and
four they've lost three in a row they've
had extra time to get ready and when you
consider what the ravens have done with
lamar jackson in two starts at home
against the bengals bengals haven't been
very good lately at home against the
raiders need i say more this is a road
game first road start for lamar jackson
it's going to be tough it's going to be
difficult it's going to be loud and that
falcons offense i think good enough to
outscore whatever lamar jackson is able
to muster i think he gets more than 50
but i don't think the ravens get the win
denver at cincinnati denver's won a
couple of games mike but they're still
four spots back out of the playoffs in
the afc is denver a legit threat if they
win this game
yeah i mean those four spots can
evaporate quickly depending upon one
team winning one team losing this team
losing you get some help they can work
their way in if they keep winning it'll
take care of itself very rarely does the
team go ten and six and not make it to
the playoffs it's happened it could
happen but
look for now the broncos turning it
around after a rough start they were
three and six they've won two in a row
beating both the chargers and the
steelers that gives them great
confidence moving forward now they have
to win the games they're supposed to win
back in late september we wouldn't have
called this a game the broncos are
supposed to win but it now is and they
need to keep stringing these victories
together and they're developing that
confidence in case keenum one thing he's
done well over the last couple of years
he's gone toe to toe with great
quarterbacks and won this week it's jeff
driscoll and who knows driscoll may come
out and play well but i think the
broncos have everything pointing into
their advantage and i do think they can
they can force their way into that
conversation for the sixth seed in the
afc the rams are going to detroit to
take on the alliance what's more likely
the lions play like the team that beat
new england or the lions play like the
team that couldn't even score a
touchdown against minnesota
yeah i i don't know and i think that
this is a team that is in the midst of a
cultural change and some weeks it works
and some weeks it doesn't they were
three and three hosting the seahawks and
many thought the lions would win that
game and that was kind of the moment we
first started to take seattle seriously
and we first started to really wonder
about the lions they're capable of
playing well they're capable of keeping
it close and maybe they will keep it
close but the rams are rested the rams
are ready and i think the rams will be
rejuvenated by the fact that the saints
have lost because now everything is
there for the rams to ensure that all of
their postseason games will be played at
home
the cardinals go to green bay to take on
the packers true or false mike the
packers are a legitimate playoff threat
in the nfc with a win
i i'd say more false than true so i
guess i have to say false i don't like
to answer true or false questions as you
know but it's going to take a lot more
it's going to take a lot more than
beating the cardinals to make me think
the packers are suddenly a playoff
contender the first thing they're going
to have to do to get me to even begin to
believe in the packers is win a game on
the road which they haven't done all
year long which look if you're not going
to win games on the road if you do make
it to the playoffs somehow as a succeed
you're not going to win in the playoffs
because you have to go on the road
although remember when they won their
only super bowl with aaron rodgers they
were the sixth seed and they went on the
road and they won in every round of the
playoffs before beating the steelers in
super bowl 45. the bills are in miami to
take on the dolphins after puckering up
late in the game last week against
indianapolis mike and losing it does
another loss spell the end for adam
gates
no and i look i i don't know i mean i
know where this is coming from because
there's been so much dysfunction in
miami over the years and and gates now
will have two straight seasons with no
playoff appearances but in his first
year he took the team to the playoffs
and they've been through a lot of
adversity the past couple of years and
the key thing to remember when they had
joe philbin as the head coach jeff
ireland as the gm donna ponte was
working in the front office those three
were constantly infighting and it was
creating many many problems for the
organization they don't have that now
even though there's plenty of external
dysfunction that has rained upon the
team and made it more difficult for them
to win they don't have the kind of
internal dysfunction that they've had in
the past and i think that means
something to an owner who isn't in
florida except for the games and i think
that adam gase is going to end up
getting another shot i think he gets a
shot with with a different quarterback
before he ends up being out the door
the bears go to new york to take on the
giants no mitchell trubisky in this game
mike chase daniel gets to start does it
matter
you know one of the weird things about
this mitchell trubisky injury it does
not affect the betting line at all which
means people have as much faith in chase
daniel as they haven't trubisky that's
that's maybe a bigger insult to trubisky
than whatever it was mike lombardi said
about him a few weeks ago so look i
think this is a real trap for the
chicago bears because they've got the
rams in prime time on the back end of
this one and the giants to their credit
have been playing everyone tough now
they're still not good enough to win
consistently but they don't go away
quietly they're going to fight hard and
this is the kind of thing where they can
get some confidence they can feel good
about themselves it's a good barometer
game for them if they can beat the bears
and it won't surprise me if they keep it
very very close and i think there's
still a chance the giants can win
panthers in tampa carolina was six and
two looking good lost lost loss as the
tailspin end this week for carolina
if it doesn't end now i don't think it
ever will because they still have two
games coming up against the saints and
look this is the best possible draw for
the panthers i know it's always tough to
go on the road in the division it's a
team that knows you very well but the
buccaneers are giving away tickets they
had their lowest attendance in eight
years and all season ticket holders got
two free tickets to this game
and uh if it's a sparse crowd that helps
the panthers and i think they do get
back on the right track and they they
continue to be a viable playoff threat
and look i don't know how that
translates to january because i think
they need to be playing their playoff
games at home but i still think they can
get in
colts at jaguars andrew luck has thrown
three or more touchdowns in eight
straight games mike over under on tds
for andy two and a half
i'm going to go ahead and say over
because jalen ramsey very well may not
play for the jaguars he's got a knee
injury and the other impressive stat
about andrew luck
last week he had his 29th or 30th 300
yard passing game of his career and that
makes him second all time for 300 yard
passing games in the first seven seasons
of a career when you consider he's lost
a season and a half to injury that's
beyond impressive if he had played the
full seven seasons he'd be challenging
dan marino if not surpassing dan marino
for the most 300 yard games in the first
seven seasons of a career and all the
markers are there to indicate that
andrew luck is as good as he's ever been
and he's a great quarterback and i saw
an item at pft during one of the breaks
because you know i multitask quentin
nelson the rookie guard from notre dame
who was a top six pick his attitude is
rubbing off on the entire line and
that's why this blue wall as chris sims
calls it is is so dominant this year the
running game is great the passing game
is great because the offensive line is
great and i think that selection of
quentin nelson is going to resonate in
indianapolis for years to come the
browns are in houston sneaky good
quarterback match up here mike which
which signal caller do you think is more
capable of putting his team on his back
i love this baker mayfield coming back
to texas storyline right baker mayfield
who played at oklahoma before that was
at texas tech coming back to take on a
texas team that has won houston team
that has won eight games in a row and
the browns have that swagger they have
that confidence and there's been so much
talk this week about baker mayfield's
comments about hugh jackson and i love
the fact that the browns finally have a
guy who will
exhibit any type of swagger it's been
too long for the browns to have someone
who's a strong personality who can
galvanize a team and take a team on his
back i still think it's going to be
tough to do against the texans because
they're healthy we know they're talented
the challenge for them over the past few
years has been health this year they're
carrying it into early december and i
think that's enough for the texans to
win even though mayfield may be better
statistically i think deshawn watson has
enough around him to pull off the
victory jets at the titans fill in the
blank for me mike the reason to watch
this game is
because it's on tv
okay let's move on
chiefs at raiders no wait wait wait i
think that there's a challenge in trying
to figure out who the titans are not
necessarily for this year but for next
year and with marcus mariota i say this
all the time what three types of teams
in the nfl teams with franchise
quarterbacks teams desperately trying to
find franchise quarterbacks and that
third category of team that has a
quarterback and they're not quite sure
what he's going to become how long do
the titans wait to figure out what
marcus mariota is going to become and
and look
he doesn't fall into the franchise
quarterback category if he can't win
easily at home against the jets so if
they stumble against the jets you have
to wonder not just about the titans this
year because i i don't think they're
going to make it the postseason but you
have to wonder long term is mariota the
answer
chiefs at raiders true or false patrick
mahomes can put drewbies behind him in
the mvp race with a good performance
i'm gonna go false because it's gonna be
a game nobody's paying any attention to
it's that late afternoon regional spot
yeah vikings patriots will be the game
that sucks up all the oxygen so patrick
mahomes throws five touchdown passes big
deal it's against the raiders and and we
kind of got to that point with mahomes
about four or five weeks into the season
oh my homes four touchdowns 350 yards uh
all right we're used to it by now so i
think mahomes is going to need a big
performance on that thursday night
coming up in 13 days against the
chargers to really put himself back at
the top of the mvp stack vikings the
patriots who just mentioned it which
number is going to be bigger kirk
cousins touchdowns or kirk cousins head
scratching throws that you like to
mention so much
well i think the touchdowns will be
larger in number but there will be
enough of those throw your shoe at the
tv moments from kirk cousins to keep the
vikings from winning look i i've seen
this movie vikings patriots with tom
brady playing quarterback four or five
times over the last generation and it
never ends well for the vikings and
taking this game to new england with a
patriots team that has rob gronkowski
though he is back on the injury report
julian edelman is healthy for the most
part
and the patriots after losing by 24 at
tennessee they have found the gas pedal
they know what's in front of them and i
still think in stats you you you text
this to me once every week or two with a
sense of dread that all this talk about
the chiefs and these other teams the
patriots are going to end up being the
number one seed in the afc there's a
sense of inevitability that that's where
this is going to land
49ers seahawks richard sherman landing
back in seattle for the first time since
leaving true or false sherman's going to
get cheers from the crowd
well here's the thing about cheers and
booze
10 percent boos will overwhelm 90 cheers
and i guarantee you there will be enough
people booing richard sherman and he
will be out there with his hands up
saying bring it on that it will overcome
the majority that will cheer him and
they should cheer him look he didn't
quit on the seahawks he didn't become a
free agent and defect to another team
the seahawks caught him anyone who is
salty about richard sherman signing with
the 49ers probably is salty about hugh
jackson going to the bengals look once
you fire a guy you assume the risk he's
gonna show up with one of your rivals
and if you don't want that to happen
don't fire him so sherman proving he can
still get it done and really if every
member of the 49ers was as talented and
dedicated as richard sherman they'd be
the team that's on the fringe of the
playoff talk right now not the seahawks
last game sunday night of course charger
steelers does phillip rivers win a game
a lot of people think he's going to lose
i don't think so i don't think so
because he doesn't have melvin gordon
that's one of the factors austin eckler
who has done well in relief of gordon
throughout the season but he's not
melvin gordon and the steelers have
james connor who has had a few rough
spots but has still shown this year he's
capable of getting it done and also the
uh juju smith schuster antonio brown ben
roethlisberger you know roethlisberger
is going to be a little salty after what
happened last week
what happened the last time we saw the
steelers in prime time against the
playoff contender what happened 52
points is what they scored they're not
going to score 52 but i think they're
going to show up in a big way and
they're going to re-inject themselves
into that conversation of the best teams
in the afc
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports